retail LEDs if it's the hydro shows you
some of the detail to the proposed
extension and then on the next slide
we've got images of the proposed
townhouses you can see some of the
detailing proposed there and there's a
color slide to follow that one
um and then the next slide that shows
you the elevations of the care home
building
and
might be it yeah so we can go back to
the slideshow sorry the site plan thanks
Karen
um so just to go back to the
introduction objections have been
received from 16 neighboring properties
in particular raising concerns regarding
the impact of the proposed development
upon the surrounding Highway Network and
parking issues 53 letters of support
have also been received it's noted that
the letters of objection have been
received from properties in close
proximity to the site on those most
likely to be affected by the proposals
whilst the letters of support are from a
wider area
the principle of a mixed use development
on this Brownfield site and in this
sustainable location is considered to be
acceptable
substantial weight is afforded to the
contribution the scheme would make
towards the council's housing land
Supply comprising the provision of 12
new housing units and a further
contribution resulting from the proposed
care home and the potential Associated
freeing up of local housing based on
National planning guidance that's the
equivalent of 28 units
the council's adult social care service
advised that there are there's an over
provision of Care Home beds in Trafford
and they've identified a number of
concerns that would result from
additional Care Home beds being provided
including in relation to impact on
business viability of existing Care
Homes recruitment of Staff additional
costs to the council and the impacts on
GP practices
nevertheless the provision of a care
home does not conflict with the
development plan and there are no
planning grounds on which a care home
can reasonably be opposed in principle
the proposed development includes the
demolition of previous inappropriate
extensions to the historic buildings the
reinstatement of a gap between the hydro
and semi-detached fillers direction of
new buildings of high quality design and
materials and an increase in soft
Landscaping across the site
the overall amount of built form and the
scale massing and citing of the proposed
Care Home are however considered to
result in minor harm to the setting of
The Bowden Conservation Area and
negligible harm
to the hail station Conservation Area
this level of harm equates to less than
substantial harm in nppf terms
it is considered that public benefits
associated with the proposed development
as set out in the planning balance and
conclusions section of the report
outweigh the harm to the Heritage assets
identified
in arriving at this conclusion
considerable importance and weight has
been given to the desirability of
preserving or enhancing the character or
appearance of the conservation areas
the scheme is considered acceptable in
terms of Highway and parking impacts
having regard to the evidence provided
in the submitted transport assessment
the existing lawful use of the site as a
hotel and the sustainable location
the local Highway Authority has raised
no objection to The Proposal
Financial contributions towards the
provision of off-site affordable housing
Health Care education open space play
facilities and sports facilities would
be secured by a section 106 agreement in
order to comply with relevant policies
and to mitigate the impacts of the
development
the additional information report refers
to revised drawings that have addressed
the number of outstanding matters
identified in the main report and in the
formal response from the council's
Heritage and Urban Design manager
a number of additional comments are also
included on a number of additional
conditions and revisions to conditions
in the main report are also recommended
thank you Tim
thank you Mr Pearson um so we'll hear
from our speakers against the proposal
first of all and I think Mr Lucas I
think you're going to speak first have
you just come and sit in the seat
opposite me
and if you just uh press the button on
the bottom of the microphone and it
should light up yeah that's it so you'll
have three minutes to speak to us
um and we'll start the timer once you
start speaking so whenever you're ready
over to you thank you
sorry Mr Lucas sorry I'm not sure the
microphones uh actually owned so
good evening councilors my family's
lived in hell for many generations and
I've been asked by the local community
opposing the current planning
application to speak on their behalf we
would like to stress that there was no
question the site at the old bone Hotel
because the development of suitable size
and design but the submitted application
for significantly short of such a scheme
and a well-loved Conservation Area
I Faithfully explained and demonstrated
in my more thorough written submission
based upon the committee report the
sheer scale of over development leading
to contentious issues relating to the
following points the loss of light and
privacy the overbearing overshadowing
overlooking and Visually inappropriate
townhouses views all shared by the local
residents Bowden conservation group
historic England hail Conservation Area
and even Elizabeth Lewis The Heritage
and Urban Design manager highway safety
traffic and parking parking issues have
been reiterated by greater Manchester
police the Bowden conservation group and
even the planning department and since
the highways report the applicant has in
fact more than doubled the projected
members of staff at the daycare facility
pollution
The increased levels of emissions due to
idling cars both on site and on streets
will be detrimental to the health of
existing residents and in particular
small children that proposed daycare
facility and the elderly at the proposed
care home
furthermore the applicants appear to be
champions of sustainable living however
are unable to meet the need for heat
pumps citing costs and space issues due
to overdevelopment something which
should have been accounted for at the
design stage historic buildings it has
been acknowledged by historic England
that there will be affected by the sheer
scale and design of the proposed care
home
the design and parents of the
development the word size scale massing
height and sighting are all regularly
referred to in the committee report
a sheer scale of the proposal has the
scheme bursting at the seams from every
direction including upwards the
infringement of Separation distances
blatant abuse of the long-standing
building line lack of car parking
facilities overshadowing overbearing and
overlooking aspects of the scheme are
all factually clear byproducts of over
development
finally you'll no doubt all be aware of
the adult social care view on the
proposed Care Facility leading to
widespread economic employment and
medical strain issues in an already
stretched sector not to mention the
contributions that you'll have to make
in 2025
myself and the local residents all agree
that something positive must happen with
the site we all understand that we will
have to compromise and it will not be a
perfect development however to a
previous scheme so imperfect without
taking into consideration any local
residence reasons for objection would
simply set precedence for developers to
Railroad what they want at the expense
of the local community with a
detrimental impact on local character
based upon what I've said myself and the
local neighbors and residents please
urge you to send back the submitted
application in order for it to be scaled
back to something appropriate and
fitting for this cherished Conservation
Area that everyone can fully support an
alternative suggestion was in fact put
forward that all local residents backed
so we know it's more than possible thank
you for your time
thank you very much Mr Lucas and thank
you for your written comments which we
uh we did receive and we and we've read
thank you very much so we yeah if you
want to take your seat um next to uh
councilor wetton uh and councilor wetton
um you're also speaking against
um I understand so
um
you'll know what happens here and as as
a ward council you'll have five minutes
to speak to us so we'll start a timer
once you start speaking thank you uh
thank you um chairman uh councilor for
Bowden Ward and I have received a lot of
representations uh concerned by this
proposal
and with any proposal of this size with
the site of this dimension in nature
it's which is almost a traffic Island
and with a comprehensive scheme
involving four types of development it's
not difficult to envisage that this
project will have presented many
competing demands and now presents
issues
I envisage two as I monitor the progress
of the application over many months that
this recommendation has been a close
call by officers and I say so because
there are clearly compromises that have
been left for future occupants or near
neighbors to take in their strides
from the introduction we saw the
proposed Street Scene and those actually
highlight the scale and massing of these
proposals
the 56 or so letters of support uh are
largely on a form letter basis and many
were generated by people being
approached in the street
for me there are several aspects of the
scheme that as drawn that are that are
at best uncomfortable at worst
unacceptable I'll come to those but for
now can I say that these with these
points in mind I'm looking to you the
committee members to see this overall
scheme as just too much for the site too
much for the neighborhood and too much
for the community it's four big elements
together and and together they are
totaling more than a hundred percent of
what should be on that site
it is inevitable with today's property
prices and Trafford property prices that
developers press to get as much into a
scheme as possible
my stance is not nimbyism it is not that
big and high near my backyard please
but I'm realistic enough not to push for
a wiping out of the plans but I hope
there can be demons it can be
demonstrated that the developers can be
urged to come back with a scheme that we
all hoped would actually emerge during
this application process one that
doesn't push too hard one that doesn't
see one that sees the neighbors points
of view rather than create viewpoints
into neighbors homes
I'll move to that point in the case of
the proposed townhouses overlooking the
existing home called Flanders and two
other homes there is a heightened
separation issue
which means overlooking will definitely
exist
we're told that officers are satisfied
that sufficient distance would be
retained between the habitable Windows
to avoid the townhouses having an
overbearing impact
well existing residents are not
satisfied that height Advantage reduces
the effect of the separation distances
and this isn't New York City people
shouldn't have to have this imposed upon
them
Alternatives were suggested but of
course they were ignored by the
applicant
it's easy enough for
officers to volunteer to sorry it's easy
enough to officers to excuse the
overbearing aspects of the properties
but it is not so easy for the person
who's living in the home that is being
overlooked
importantly Trafford adult social care
cons concerns over more care provision
are clearly stated within the report and
I've taken the opportunity to raise this
with the director of adult care
the concern is significant and is still
very much the case
if there are no planning grounds that
recognize the situation then there ought
to be in planning we know we get chapter
and verse to deal with supermarkets even
though not many of us spend our final
days in a supermarket I believe it is
essential that this serious portent of
the destabilizing of the local adult
care Market is taken into consideration
but certainly by this um committee
hopefully by this committee tonight
the impact on our elderly and on our
council's ongoing adult care is not
acceptable and I repeat myself I have
rechecked this situation with the
director of adult care as recently as
last night her position is consistent an
increase even on this scale will
destabilize the local care provision to
the detriment of the borough's elderly
residents
surely one arm of the council should be
mindful of the needs of another vital
arm of the same Council
yeah
it apparent 228 only two adverse impacts
are noted mentioning I'll just be very
brief now for my chairman mentioning the
conservation areas in Simone street
parking we know there are more adverse
features than that the overlooking the
size the scale and massing traffic
traffic to these should not be ignored
the benefits listed at para 230 can
likely all be achieved on a scaled back
proposal putting a more realistic array
of features on this important site
uh concluded at that point thank you for
that thank you councilor wetton thank
you for coming to speak to us
um we've got um two speakers in in favor
of the application now I think first
we'll have um Mr Garner and Miss
fairhurst are you both with us
so I understand you want to share the
allotted three minutes
um
do you want three minutes and then just
swap when you're ready or do you want a
minute and a half each
um
it's about so fast that's okay well
we'll just do the timer for three
minutes and I think that should give us
sufficient time so we'll um we'll start
the clock uh once you start speaking
thank you
[Music]
thank you Miss fairhouse Mr Garner thank
you very much for coming this evening
um and now we'll hear from uh councilor
boys
um
if you want to come and join us
counselor boys because you're um not a
counselor for the ward
um I'll give you three minutes please
yeah thank you so we'll start the clock
when you start speaking thank you
thank you Mr chairman for allowing me
the opportunity to speak I've been aware
of this building and this site for over
50 years since it was there in July 1972
that I had my wedding reception and over
the years I've attended many functions
there
although very impressive from its
Langham Road facade like many other
commercial buildings the appearance of
its rear has for many years left much
much to be desired and in addition
although functional the Steep turn into
the large car park is not the easiest
and the Landscaping of that car park
certainly not the most pleasing on the
eye
I fully support the application for two
main reasons first because it retains a
significant proportion of the character
of that impressive facade and indeed
adds to it in a very sympathetic manner
secondly because it takes what is by its
Origins an 18th century building with
extensions which has effectively now
served its time and in a changing world
is no longer fit and by retaining the
best aspects of those buildings
establishes a mixed use
multi-generational complex of quality
design in keeping with the area that
should serve its Newfound purpose well
into the 22nd century
furthermore I can say that in the last
10 days I have visited four of the
almost 60 care homes in the borough and
expect to visit at least another 10 in
the next two months in every case I have
found them to be almost fully subscribed
and with a long-serving Content
Workforce
for professional reasons since early
1980s I have been very very aware of the
Aging population and the implication of
morbidity associated with it this has
always implied that there was to be an
ever increasing requirement for Care
Home capacity at least until the
mid-2050s by which time the bulk of the
so-called baby boomers born from around
1946 to 1964 will have by then been
accommodated as said Mr chairman I fully
support the application thank you
thank you councilor boys
um that ends the um discussion smart air
speakers
um okay I've got two speakers just bear
with me one moment
uh catch the Fremont start with you
thank you thank you chair
um first of all I want to thank the
writer of the report because I think
it's obviously been a very complex
report to write but it's well set out I
also want to say that I recognize the
need for this site to be redeveloped
that said I have concerns
and my concerns come around the care
home which was highlighted by councilor
wetton I heard what Mr Pearson says and
I understand that you should hunt any
weight against this development but I do
think
out of loyalty to this Council and the
council is my first loyalty
that when senior officers are telling us
we don't need a care home and the
potential ramifications for the council
its finances and the Care Home Market if
this is approved I think we as a body
need to listen very very carefully
and I just want to to indulge you in in
some of the things that I've I've been
finding out
um and I'm going to relate back to the
time I was on the executive and through
through the pandemic when we were buying
as a council Care Homes
and and the the the the the corporate
director for adult social care will say
that the optimum size of a car was 40
beds and anything over that
is impersonal
and that the operating model for Care
Homes is based on a 90 occupancy
and currently we've got over 150 beds of
vacant in care homes in Trafford
Ashland's mother was mentioned by one of
the speakers in favor a 70-plus bedroom
beds there I remember when the
application was made for Russians money
we were told oh yeah uh when it was
approved we've got to have 70 plus beds
because that's when it's viable I just
wonder what the occupancy rate of
Ashland's matter is and I inquired about
that today and it's about 50 percent
against the business model of 90
occupancy
and this Care Homes 51 beds foreign
will destabilize the market and then we
look at the 2025 legislation this will
be a high-end care home charging a lot
of money
and people will come here from not just
around the Bowden area or the Trafford
area they'll come into Trafford if the
2025 legislation to come to proposing on
adult social care is enacted once
they've spent the hundred thousand pound
on care the full cost of their care
Falls to this Council not where they've
come from
and currently anyone's assets that go
below 23 and a half thousand pounds
under the current legislation the full
cost of the Care falls on this Council
and we've already got an Asian
population in Trafford so if this is
going to attract other people in from
outside the borough again
it's going to destabilize the market
and
one thing that bothered me about this is
that
I could have accepted this whole
development if they are applicant and
looked at an extra Care Facility an
extra Care Facility an extra care
facilities are desperately needed in
Trafford like Fiona Gardens we've got in
in in sale
where you have the people have their own
individual flat it's Warden controlled
it's that is this and if it's been but
you ask yourself well why haven't they
gone for that because you don't get 51
people in you might only get 20 Flats
and it just comes down to what you can
maximize out it out of it
so
we've had the objections there from
adult social care we've had the
objections there from the GP uh from the
ccg my understanding is irrespective of
who anyone's registered with a doctor if
they go into a care home all the
patients in that care home come under
1gp practice and this capacity problem
is right across this Borough I'm going
to leave other aspects chair up to
others to bring in but I think that is
something that irrespective of what Mr
Pearson has said we as a committee need
to think carefully about the possible
ramifications for Trafford Council our
biggest spend is adult social care
I'll leave it at that chair thank you
okay thank you councilor Freeman uh
councilor minutes
thank you chair
um I agree with a lot of what you said
councilor Freeman
um the what I was going to say my part
so I want the way I saw it was happy for
I absolutely one to Brownfield site to
be developed
glad to see housing on there don't need
a care home we don't need a care home I
think we've got we you've explained it
at length and we've got a number of
people explaining length we don't need a
care home what I'd like to sin is more
housing more homes
um that's what I would have liked to see
and yes they're not going to be
affordable because it's Bowden but I
would like to see more more homes
because that will actually help uh
towards our our housing supply problem
and we'll reduce what we build on the
green belt so that's what I would like
to see I've got a number of things and I
I'm glad that you said about the number
of residents you should have in a care
home I've I have worked as a carer um in
my past and I'll tell you now 51
um is too many to make it
um actually looking after people
properly
um I also say that the nursery I think
is rather large 95
um a place Nursery again it's the same
sort of thing I I mean I don't know how
you're going to fit 95 children in there
the ratios how many adults are going to
have needing to care for the 95 so it's
a lot and again I don't think it's a
suitable size I'd like to see that
reduced I'd like to see a different
development I don't I don't have a
problem with a nursery per se I have a
problem with the care home and I'd like
to see I'd like a smaller nursery and
housing rather than a care home I guess
it's not my choice this is the
application in front of me and it's the
application that I will look at and and
the term I you know I wrote on its
merits and and thereafter when we're
told that it's not up for planning a
reason to say about the care home the
fact is we are weighing public benefits
here with
um what what detriment there is and the
detriment to the public is
um is going to be problems with adult
social care beings you know the council
being saddled with it that does for that
in my mind does fall into the negative
and
um the pros they're having a care home
there is not a positive
um the land should be better used so I'm
I I'm happy to propose that we refuse
this application
um so I'd like to start the ball rolling
with a refusal and see how the rest of
you all go thank you okay councilman
we'll have some advice now from Miss
curly because
um you made a lot of comments about what
you'd like to see on the site well that
isn't the decision for us it's a
councilor minutes just a minute please
you've made a lot of comments about that
and we have to deal with the application
that is before us okay so I hear your
proposal to refuse I think if we are
minded to refuse then we need reasons
for refusal and I don't think I heard
any planning reasons for refusalem what
you said so I'll come to miss curly now
thank you chairman
um
I understand that everybody in front of
me in the planning committee is also a
member of council and as members of
council you will naturally be concerned
about an impact on the adult social care
that's completely understandable but you
are also a planning committee and a
planning committee must make decisions
on planning grounds
you cannot make them on grounds which
are not playing grounds and the two
points on the care home in terms of need
and in terms of its impact on the
finances the council are not planning
reasons that's been established by
previous appeal decisions if you try to
refuse it on that we we will lose an
appeal
and it will not be a good situation
and you'll end up with the care home
anyway so
um I really do I understand your
concerns if you are concerned about this
then you have other means at your
disposal as Ward councilors and members
of council to bring forward
um proposals however you see fit to
assist adult social care but this
unfortunately is not the way to do it if
it was then obviously we would be
setting that out in the report and you
say you've heard from senior officers in
adult social care this is a problem
please hear it from senior officers in
the planning department that it isn't
the role of planning to try and fix it
I'm sorry about that but it but it
simply isn't so I really really do
advise very strongly against refusing
the application on the grounds that
there is no need for the care home thank
you chairman
thank you Miss curly I know there's a
gentleman at the back with his hands up
but as I explained at the start of the
item on the applications we we can't
hear from uh members of the public who
are here once we first met speakers okay
so the debate will just be among members
of the committee
um councilor chalkin you want to speak
[Music]
thank you thank you chair
um
[Music]
there's some positives on this one
um the Design's quite good for a change
quite like it uh sympathetic to
what's there and there's a lot of
thought they've gone into it I think
it's worth noting or worth acknowledging
the the work that both the applicants
and the officers have done to try and
bring an exceptional application to us
um there's a lot of work that's clearly
gone on and there's a lot of willing to
show by the applicant to um contribute
to the local finances and
I really like the I the concept of care
home with a nursery and housing the
intergenerational use to me is is a huge
positive and it's something that perhaps
should be locked out why more widely but
that's not really a planet consideration
where I really struggle
is on two points one is the size of the
proposed development I
from London Road yes it's it's set back
it will be as unobtrusive or as the
existing one is I suppose but from
Marlborough Road the proposed care home
is fairly monolithic and it
the houses opposite uh or the the the
from the views offices I don't I
disagree that it's not going to cause
any harm to to them it will be
overshadowing it will it won't
be great so I
I think that it's slightly it's too big
a development
um for what it is I also take issue with
the parking
um I don't think there's enough spaces I
know it's acknowledging the report for
the houses or for the housing that there
isn't quite enough spaces and there's
it's going to be shared between
nursery and
the townhouses for stroke Apartments but
in all honesty they're going to have two
cars per house probably two cars per
apartment there
um if there's a 51 back at home you have
no idea really how many cars are going
to come without the car Park's going to
get quite full which means it's then
going to spell us onto the road um I'm
not going to go we've gone and learn
from those committees and this committed
before about nursery drop-offs and
Pickups I'm not going to bring that up
because
I don't believe that's going to have an
impact but the actual residential use
will have an impact on the surrounding
roads
and that road is full during the day
um oxygen grammar uses
um Park on Melbourne Road the prep
school next door they Park on Melba Road
throughout the day it is full so I
really do have concerns about the
transport side of things the highway
side
um I also do take issue with the report
and it's probably just
um because I live in the area it's not a
sustainable location that yes there's
bus routes but they're very infrequent
yes it's close to hail station but
you've only got one throw in an hour
that doesn't always run
um it's within walking distance of
ultragon but if you're visiting the go
home with a family or if you're an
elderly person you aren't going to be
walking to Ultram so it's I take issue
with the idea that's it's sustainable
um so for me my mind had to actually
move to refuse but
on the massing and transport grounds I
don't think it's it's actually
going to be a great development it's the
principle is good
um it's Brownfield site that's going to
be put back into use housing is good I
agree with councilman it's great similar
housing there
um but I think it's it's too big
um it's going to overshadowed another
road uh and it's going to affect the
transport
um so I would propose to refuse it on
those grounds
thank you councilor choking uh councilor
wealth she wanted to speak
thanks Jay
um I just want to explore the uh the
issue around the care home because I've
been on on this committee quite a long
time and I can remember we refuse an
application some years back
and and I'm I could be wrong but I'm
sure one of the reasons was because it
wasn't a need for a care home and I've
been looking through the
the council's web page and and memory
tell me it was on bancor Lane it was an
application on Bank online and this call
we'll know better than me but what's
that issue talked about it
that decision about
than not being a need for a Care on the
reason I say that's when I read that
when I first picked up the application
it came to me straight away which was
surprising
that there's an abundance of Care Homes
embolden and these are rather than that
area of the borough and there's been so
for for many many years
um certainly going back to that
application but I didn't I'd be
interested in hearing what Miss Coley
has to say about that thank you
um
it was a few years ago Council Walsh so
um I will tell you what I can remember
about it but I'm also going to have a
quick look back at the appeal decision
as well because you're right it was
refusing it did go to appeal my memory I
think was that
um we didn't refuse the application on
the fact that there was no need for a
care home albeit that was raised and
that's been raised in a number of uh
members will recalled Pelican that came
to you maybe six months ago or so where
we said
um there was no need for the care home
but that wasn't a reason for refusal
that was just weighed as a neutral
impact because
um
in terms of the balance because there
were other reasons for refusing that
application which which were far more
substantial and indeed
um that appeal was dismissed Bank call
Lane I think
um was uh refused on design
um
and uh appearance but also on the fact
that the site was unsuitable for a care
home because of the it wasn't a
sustainable location and that the
Pavements
um the sort of access and the means of
elderly people getting out and about
would be very difficult
um and the inspector if I recall
correctly supported that but I don't
think concluded on The Wider point of
whether there was a need or not again
there were there were other issues and
there have been other ones that that
um that have that have come forward
where again
we may not have supported the
application overall but the care home
need was not a reason particular reason
for refusal
but I will have a look at the at the
bank Hall Lane decision and if I was an
incorrect in any way I will clarify
thank you Miss colic and councilors I'll
come back to you thank you for raising
that thanks for indulging me Chet um
perhaps looking at from another point of
view then
um will we to turn down this application
for uh a reason and a very good reason
because all the councils are out in this
room want to support the council and
they certainly don't want to put into
any kind of financial Jeopardy I think
councilor Freeman put put the issue very
fairly fairly succinctly but if we were
to refuse the application on those
grounds my understanding is we would
lose a lot of control over the
application of experience of that not
with a similar application something
very much smaller in my own mode where
we refuse the application and may I say
much to the Delight of the residents I
had plenty of people patting me on the
back actually
the residents turned out in a worse
situation because there weren't controls
in place for that application and the
building company ran roof shoved over
any regulations and and been and it's
been a very unpleasant experience for
the resident and continues to be an
unpleasant experience so just unround
that
through you chair can I ask if we were
to refuse the application on those
grounds and the and the applicant quite
reasonably went to appeal what situation
would be would we be losing control of
the application in the sense that they
can uh regulate the application
themselves if you like have their own
site surveyor if I may put it like that
thank you
thank you uh let's go thank you
um we would no longer be the decision
maker um because the uh applicant would
no doubt appeal it would then be up to
the inspector what conditions were
imposed on the application what sections
106 requirements it would open it all up
again you're right
um we would obviously recommend the
conditions that we have uh on the
application at the moment that would be
the the um the sensible thing to do
I can't say what would happen in terms
of what the inspector would do but I can
confirm that the council would no longer
be the decision maker
just come back briefly just we would we
lose control over regulation of The
Works taking place off the developer
built it to a you know two foot higher
than it should be or not in the right
position on site would does it weaken
our position in that system
it doesn't I think I know the scheme
that you're referring to council Walsh
and I think I think
um part of part of the issue is that was
was the inspector didn't see fit to put
um put a robust construction management
plan on as opposed to
um and I think there were some some
discrepancies in the plans
um which
um again made it difficult to enforce
against specific so
I wouldn't say that what happened on
that site would necessarily happen on on
this site because
you've got two very different developers
and two very different sites
thank you Miss Kelly
um cancer the protter
thank you chair
I went to visit the site
um I I too know it from my niece and
nephew's 21st birthdays
when it was a hotel
and I
was stuck in a traffic jam for nearly 10
minutes before I could get into the car
park
I drove around the building
I drove down the very steep bit of the
car park
and
had a good look around building
and then drove back up the very steep
part of the car park
and then waited for quite a long time
before I could get out of the junction
because of the volume of traffic
so
I've got to really strong concerns about
this application one the traffic
management
or three actually concerns the traffic
management
if it's
difficult to get out this was at three
o'clock if it was difficult to get in
and out of the car park at three o'clock
how on Earth will
all those residents
um
all the members of staff
and all the
the people in either using the nursery
or working for the nursery get in and
out
so I've got an issue about that I've got
an issue about the parking spaces there
aren't sufficient
for the number of people who are going
to be working and living there but also
about the massing of the site I think
it's far too big
and there are going to be real issues of
overlooking
of neighbors so in line with other
counselors
I think I'm going to be voting against
this thank you chair
thank you councilor Proctor councilor
Morgan
thanks Jeff
um I'm probably gonna
um
repeat to honestly a lot of the the
concerns that cancer Proctors
um
um raised
um so I
I mean I'm not to go back over the issue
about social care but I share the
sentiments of cancer medicine councilor
Freeman but I don't think it is it's
it's a planning reason to to reject this
um and there's a number of other items I
don't think it's probably an over
development to the site
um
um
but there's two concerns I've got which
is it's
one relates to parking and traffic and I
think you could probably put put those
concerns together and a lot of people
have mentioned the issues in the day but
actually I mean I know this site
relatively well because I take my son to
rugby touch on a Saturday morning and
there are times when there are no cars
on on Marble road but if there's a
football game and a rugby game and a
cricket game Authority boys it's it's
actually it's chaos there's no parking
at all alter boys
um so I think it's it's an it's a
strange site in that that it can have
quite a big generation of of parking
issues
and if there is then additional parking
problems I think that's definitely a
concern not just in the week but also
the weekend when you might have a
greater number of people visiting
um
and then on height the distance to the
which actually I think is a fact we were
adding a bit of a flop an additional
flaw onto the buildings which are on
opposite Marlborough Road we're adding
additional properties opposite other
other
um properties that don't currently exist
and actually something which is it's the
it's the shorter distance to the road
now it is a substantial site
but that all of those things combined
together will have quite a significant
impact which is massing effectively
um and then I think this particular
residential immunity problem issues on
the Flanders number four Marlborough
Road
um
site
I'm not sure how I'm going to vote yet
um really interested in what other
people have had to say
um
um but I do have concerns but I do also
want to reiterate what councilor talk
and said I do think there's a lot of
positives about this and it definitely
is a massive Improvement on the design I
don't think there's a problem on the
impact on the conservation area which
some some people have objected to I
actually think this is an improvement on
the conservation area
um but it is definitely traffic parking
issue and the massing issue um
residential immunity thank you
thank you councilor Morgan any other
members looking to speak
uh yeah welcome to Mr Pearson just to
give some further advice on some of the
points that we made thank you thank you
chairman yes I just thought bearing in
mind the the concern that's been
expressed by members about
um a number of issues is just worth
um
uh just kind of directing you to the
report
um just to point out a few a few issues
so concern has been expressed about car
parking now in terms of the council's
maximum car parking standards set out in
spd3
um just for clarity the day Nursery
requires 18 car parking spaces
um what's proposed are 14 spaces that
are entirely dedicated to the day
nursery and then seven spaces which will
be dedicated to the day Nursery whilst
it is open
so that's 21 spaces three more than the
maximum parking standards required in
terms of the care home spd3 requires or
sets a maximum of 10 car parking spaces
and 21 parking spaces are proposed so
more than twice the maximum number of
parking spaces
the townhouses now sbd3 there sets a
maximum provision of 18 spaces that's
based on three spaces per house and
there are only 12 dedicated spaces for
for each of the townhouses that said of
course
um those seven spaces which are not used
um when the day Nursery is open would be
available to those residents I think
it's also worth bearing in mind that
since those standards were set back in I
think 2012
um and given what we consider to be a
sustainable location it would be a very
rare occasion when we would insist on
three parking spaces per house you know
when we're trying to encourage people to
leave their cars at home and use other
forms of Transport so we feel that two
spaces for each of the townhouses is is
reasonable
for the apartments
um SPD would require
um 12 spaces that's two for each of the
apartments and nine are proposed so a
slight shortfall there but again bearing
in mind the sustainable location of the
site and those seven spaces which are
available when the when the day
nurseries not open so on the parking
front I think trying to put together or
Justify a reason for refusal on the
inadequate car parking provision would
be really quite difficult bearing in
mind our own standards and bearing in
mind that those are maximum standards
um in relation to the
um concern expressed about the general
traffic on the surrounding roads and how
easy or not it is to gain and out of the
site I mean we have to bear in mind the
fallback position here which which is
out of the hotel and you'll have no
doubt seen in the report the the
information based on the the tricks the
trips to to from the site and and how
that compares the proposed development
compares to the hotel
I mean the
the there's a there's going to be fewer
trips associated with
um with the proposed development overall
than there are with the existing if the
hotel were used you know operated to to
capacity which is what you have to do
that's the way we have to assess it
so there's no suggestion slight very
slight increase in uh trips in the peak
am and Peak PM points so we'll be
talking about one car in the morning
Peak and two cars in the afternoon Peak
so would be very difficult to justify a
refusal based on on on those impacts as
well
um
the other points are are some members of
Express concern about residential
amenity I mean again when you look at
the the residential amenity section of
the of the report the scheme does
to all intents and competitors comply
with the council's guidelines on on
separation distances now we note of
course that there is a slight shortfall
in relation to one relationship with a
property known as Flanders uh across
Marlborough Road but we and and we
acknowledge of course that there's this
site sits at a higher level than
Flanders but notwithstanding that we
think that that those are guidelines and
we think that these relationships are
acceptable
so I just wanted to make those points uh
make members aware of those points
bearing in mind they that the way the
debate's gone this evening thank you
thank you
thank you very much Mr Pearson um any
other members looking to speak councilor
Welton
hey it's been a while
um it's a desperate it's desperate um I
think we all you know for many reasons
really want to
to refuse this application principally
because of the impact on the Care Home
Market as has been you know very
yeah that was
has been attested to by fellow
councilors on the other side of the room
um and you know I'm listening listening
hard because I would like to join join
them in
in wanting to you know to protect the
council's position in that basis
um but I'm trying to look at the
planning reasons that we've got for
refusal
um I thought you know particularly the
the the highways issues because I mean
like a lot of people like regularly
travel past this I regularly
particularly cycle along Langham Road
and I use the horrendous Junction with
Langham Road Marlborough Road and quite
frankly something it was very frequently
terrifying and the idea of putting more
traffic on there is is is is
is quite horrendous
um you know particularly with the
vehicles turning in and out but of
course we have the issue that it is as
we've just had explained to us it is a
you know it has been a hotel before and
it could be again so those movements
could come in anyway I have turned to as
I sometimes do I've turned to crash map
um which is a service where you can see
how many incidents that have there have
been
um on a site and you know actually the
the roads along there haven't had a huge
amount you know there's nothing reported
on Langham Road or Marlborough Road
there are several minor incidents from
you know over a decade ago from The
Junction
um uh their reported incidents but
nothing that would suggest that it's a
you know that site is is a major cause
of of uh collisions on that side so it
would be very very difficult to get that
to stack up
um you know if it went to uh if it went
to appeal that's very difficult I the
only what the only
justification that seemed we would seem
to have you know solid reason for
approving for for disapproving this
application would be the um the the
scale of massing
um which is you know and I think we need
to decide as a committee that whether
that is going to be sufficient to get
this through because I don't see any
other genuine
much though I would like to see it I
don't see any other genuine
um
planning reason for getting it through
and obviously we're looking at the
financial viability of the council in
the future that can be affected by Care
Homes but also if we lose a planning
appeal that's going to cost a lot of
money as well
so you know it's we've got scales here
we have to find solid planning reasons
and you know I hope we can find them but
I'm not heard them yet I think
um thank you counselor Welton I think
what we need to bear in mind is that
we're dealing with the application
before us and there's a presumption in
favor of sustainable development
so
our comments need to be addressed to
that rather than what is the reason to
refuse this but I appreciate
um
I appreciate the objective I think in
your comments in that
um
I think what I understood you were
saying is that some of the reasons
for refusing this application that have
been Advanced you don't actually agree
with
um
but you think the massing probably is
the only one which which would be a
valid reason for you for useful but I
think we just need to be careful if we
could in in the way in which we address
the application so we're not looking for
reasons to refuse we are looking for
bearing in mind this is a tilted balance
application we're looking at whether the
adverse impacts
um significantly outweigh the benefits
okay uh cancel that bunting did you want
to speak yeah we'll come to you then yes
thank you chairman especially with your
previous comments sort of in my ears as
I was going to take a very similar line
to the previous speaker I accept that
presumption is in favor unless there is
a reason not to and I accept that but
it's often in my mind very useful often
sometimes to flip around and sort of
examine the reasons of refusal and see
if they Stack Up
and uh in many ways they don't in
relation to this application whilst I'm
extremely sympathetic with the argument
portfolio by councilor Freeman and I can
see that as a major concern I also
accept the point made by Mrs Coley that
this is not a relevant uh matter for us
to consider in relation to this yes I
accept also that there were many
positives and there were many negatives
to this one especially the frontage to
Marvel which I think is pretty
awful but uh
unfortunately that massing and that
aesthetic effect is perhaps not
sufficient to to warranty refusal in
relation to this especially when you
take into account the other positives
although there are many other negatives
also
um whilst I'm so uh and so it is perhaps
one of those ones where you are looking
at with very little enthusiasm
uh being given little or no option to
vote in favor although I'm certainly not
in a mood to propose such
um so with that said unless someone has
got something that I haven't thought of
and I've been through this quite
carefully and I've visited the site and
I've tried to look at all the concerns
raised I think it does meet with the
criteria that we have to operate within
no matter how many problems we may see
for the future in relation to sites such
as this we are constricted and confined
to dealing with that which we are tasked
to deal with I.E the planning rules and
the regulations we you know the fact
that you would see other problems
associated with it the fact that you
dislike it in many ways for various
reasons is not something that we're able
to to take into account
and so although I think
through our some aspects when yes cancer
talking points out the design is better
than the sun although in many ways
that's not saying a great deal when it
comes to this kind of site you know
um it is perhaps a a small Improvement
on those as you've seen before but then
again as we're also saying on many
occasions we have to deal with each site
individually comparing it to others that
we didn't like is not something that we
can really do so on this I'm minded that
we are perhaps edging towards uh voting
in favor but I'm certainly not
interested in proposing anything thank
you chairman
okay thank you Council bunting so I know
uh Council medicine councilor Morgan I
think wanted to speak again uh I'm going
to bring in councilor wins down there
because he's not spoken on the item yet
and then I'll come to the other two uh
thank you chair I've delivered not spoke
until the almost the end of the debate
because I
when I read the report when I went to
see the site this
the science needs something developing
and yet I could generate no enthusiasm
for the scheme that's in front of us for
all the reasons we've talked about
already
the uh the problems with traffic I think
they'll be generated from the traffic
but the report deals with that in a fair
amount of detail the parking's not ideal
the report deals without in a fair
amount of detail
um the mashing of the care home
matter of opinion I think it's
borderline
um whether it's overly matching or not
um should the beer Care Home there well
are all that is our own adult
um social care Department says no we'll
begin very clear advice from the uh from
the planning team that's not
uh something we can take into account to
refuse this
um I've got to stress I did look at it
with any enthusiasm but I didn't look
for it specifically with a reason to
refuse it
so I think on balance that I will be
reluctantly voting for this because I
can see no
um culmination of reasons which give
sufficient planning grounds to refuse it
thank you chair thank you councilman
Stanley councilman
um although I didn't quite state it in
what I was saying before I mean I I said
to you that I do want to Brownfield
development do want housing that's the
positives
um I don't have anything
um against the nursery I think that's
great I like the idea of um the three
types together but I think that the only
planning reason would be the size and
nothing I think I understand that
um as much as we don't need a care home
that's not a planning thing
um but I'd be happy to go to say that
I'm still not going to be voting for it
I'm afraid I don't think anyone can
convince me otherwise
um and they will be on the grounds of
the scale of massing of it the parking
to me is less of a cons less of a
concern I actually wasn't it wasn't an
issue for me
um it was it was more and the highways
thing again if it was brought back as a
hotel you'd you'd have cars coming and
going anyway so
um it was yeah the scale of massing of
the building
thank you thank you cancer Melissa
Council Morgan
uh thank you chair not really much more
to add um after what Mr Pearson said
um uh given the
um that length of debate we've already
had um and uh Council buntings and
reluctance to propose
um I don't think there's any reasons for
on applying ground to um refuse this so
um I propose that we
um
um approve the scheme in line with
officer recommendations thank you
Hassan I'll bring you into this
um thank you
it is of course looks very complex but
what was option then because it was a
hotel and
and they are going to make a multiple uh
building for
opening three dimensions uh to use for
the care home and Town Hall houses
townhouses and of course for the
third options and one question because
officers has already covered all the
legal points we I mean we need to decide
not on the emotional keep the emotions
here and other sides and keep the legal
points on one side where we are going
ahead because we need local development
and we need to look into the study about
the local uh local development plan what
the local developer plan is saying so in
my point of view it looks difficult but
what was the best option for this then
because they are creating three they are
covering all segments okay homes and of
course the social home and the
townhouses
and there is no issue at all for the
traffic because they are not going to
bury the high school there and almost 50
80 cars are coming out and going out and
coming and going out and and I mean it
looks me uh absolutely fine and then and
it will increase the local revenue on of
course and unemployment as well and it
will cover
almost
all the expects what we need locally in
Trafford
and I will I will definitely support
this application
thank you councilor Santa Godzilla
Proctor
thank you chair I can't believe I didn't
think to ask this and this is to the
planning officers please I couldn't see
anything about accessible parking spaces
I couldn't see anything about
um
homes that
people with additional needs would be
able to live in
have I missed that please thanks
I'm coming to Mr Pearson I know there is
some information in the middle infill
report about the accessible parking but
I'll ask Mr Pearson to yes thank you
sorry China thank you um there are
accessible parking spaces proposed for
for each element of the developments
um there are three spaces for the day
Nursery
um at The Point close to the egress at
the top left of your screen there
um there are three disabled parking
spaces for the care home
um kind of bottom left just the left of
the the edge of the care home as you see
it on the screen there and there are two
disabled parking spaces within that car
park in the center of the site which is
to be shared between the apartments and
um and the care home
um so there is and then in terms of the
townhouses
um there are no dedicated accessible
parking spaces but I think the
arrangement of the parking spaces so I
was discussing this with miss engine
earlier we feel that there's scope there
for for you know to for people in a
wheelchair to be able to get in and out
of those uh out of their cars within
that within that section of the site
um so sorry you mentioned um accessible
parking and sorry it was one it was
another thing lifetime homes live yeah
um no I don't think
um there's any m42 homes but certainly
in terms of accessibility there's
um that there are lifts proposed to to
the in the care home in the day nursery
and in the apartment block to all floors
so uh that particular Point's covered
thank you thank you
thank you councilor so Council Welsh
thanks just briefly I think we've had a
good debate on this um I'm going to be
voting in favor of the application
um just to talk about that that wedge
between Langham Road and Marlborough
Road it's a very very prominent site and
um
the Heritage Urban Design manager
Heritage England and some of the
residents bold and conservation Society
of expressed concerns about that design
that wedge is a very very prominent
location looking at the photo supplied
by the developer and I really don't
think it enhances the area and I don't
think it's good enough for that area but
as the officers have said they've read
the contribution from our heritage
people and the the benefits outweigh
that concern but I I do think there's an
argument there not enough perhaps to to
refuse the application but it's such a
prominent location people see that as
they go down that road I'm sure many
years have been down that way many many
times and you want the best possible
design then I have to say uh to be like
I don't think that's the best and I
think that could have been so much
better but I'll be supporting the
application share thank you thank you
councilor Welsh um cancer Freeman I'll
come to you and then I I think we should
probably move to vote on the emotions
we've got thank you just to say chair I
started when I opened up by thanking the
right of the report and I made some
notes before today before I even went
into what I went into and I actually
concluded I think her hands are tied on
this
and I regret to say that very much so
because I don't like the development
I've got no enthusiasm for it I know the
site needs developing but I think our
hands are tied and in that case I'm
going to have to vote
um alongside the colleagues in favor of
the application
thank you councilor Freeman um
so it has been moved and seconded that
we refuse uh
okay sorry I thought um councilor
chalking I know you you were happy to
propose and I think you were councilor
ministers that does that remain yeah
it's um
no no no I think I have what because
Council Municipal where you were when
you propose to refuse it the that you
then give planning grounds so I said if
we were to propose to refuse at Mass
England's transport and then you came
back and said so I don't know yeah so
you can say that a second question if
you want those
poster not even checking that it's
modern so so um
councilor Morgan I I thought was
speaking broadly in favor of granting oh
um yeah so I I did propose uh and cancer
Okay so we've got motions to refuse and
to grant that both been moved and
seconded
um
so I you know I suspect this will be
closed so I should probably just say
something myself actually I think
um
I I think I think this is a really
difficult one and I'm I'm not
enthusiastic about the application uh at
all I have to say men are because of the
the care home but I fully accept that's
not a relevant planning consideration
um and I know that members have raised
some really badly concerned some of
which I agree with some of which I don't
I think the design is okay
um
possibly bada care home which I think
probably isn't in keeping I don't think
the heritage is is is is really
adversely affected I think if anything
it's beneficial
um
the sustainability of the buildings
isn't great gas fire boilers you know no
heat network but again it does
um meet with guidance so I don't think
that's a reason for refusal
I'm I'm concerned about the parking
um
and the impact that will have on highway
safety so I don't think the the
traffic on the road the I don't think
congestion is a concern I think I think
the report demonstrates that through the
the data on trips on uh in that location
bearing in mind the fallback position of
it being used as a hotel
um but I do think the combination of
the shortfall in parking compared to the
maximum standards will create a problem
and and sort of problem I'm anticipating
is
um is is the drop off and pick up at the
nursery
um and I and I worry that a lot of that
will occur actually on the road and
you know I'm sure parents on the
committee know what it's like you're
rushing to drop off children get to work
and park up and and you know what what
counselor Welton said I thought was was
really about I mean it's not a it's not
a nice Junction to to cycle through I
think I think I'd probably avoid it
actively avoid it um so that does really
concern me that is flagged in the report
as an adverse impact and
um
you know it it feels uncomfortable to me
that we're saying there could be an
impact on highway safety but
um that isn't sufficient reason to
refuse the application but but I think
that's right because I think
as other members have articulated
there are a lot of there are a lot of
benefits to this scheme and I and I
don't think the the reasons to refuse a
lot we've heard
um I don't I don't think we'll we'll
carry uh much weight I think the design
on the whole is good the residential
amenity broadly complies with Guidance
the parking I am concerned about
um
I was quite struck by what you said
counselor chalking that it's not
actually sustainable location I suppose
that impacts on the parking and the
highway safety possibly
the massing and the overlooking and the
scale I think we would need to
articulate that better as a reason for
refusal
um I can see that it might be over
development of the site
um standing in the car park and sort of
looking at how many buildings we're
going to be there
um but I think we would need to
articulate that more clearly and I'm not
convinced that would be a reason for
refusal so that's where I am on the
application I I reluctantly think that
we uh that we should approve the officer
recommendation to Grant permission here
um
those speakers who um
were minded to refuse I don't know if
you want to
so we do need to come up with the ground
for refusal so I don't know those who
wanted to refuse if you want to
um clarify which of those you think are
are good reasons to refuse and and
articulate those if possible thank you
again just a minute yeah happy happy to
say um so for me it was the um it was
the scale massing I think the
overlooking
um loss of immunity to neighboring
residents
um is where I would would go with
um I'd for me it wasn't the parking um
so and I know that the highways thing it
could it could be a hotel if it was a
viable business so
um but yes it was a scale massing and
overlooking was the harm counselor the
harm um is well it's it's there's too
much on the site it's an over
development on the side to the harmless
to the residents a lot the the
overlooking there's a loss of amenity to
the residents nearby
from scale of massing but it meets the
guidelines is it an impact on the street
scene design Heritage what what is it
about the scale of muscle which makes it
harmful we can't just say scale of
massing it's not enough I understand
what you're saying um I guess I'd say
that it's not in keeping with what is in
the area
um I'd say it's out of keeping
the the scale of it and massing of it is
out of keeping of the area
I don't think it fits at all
okay so again we
um
is the is the harm to the street scene
is a harm to the conservation area what
what is the harm to
if it's not in keeping what is the harm
something can mean not in keeping but
not harmful do you see what do you see
what I mean
then sorry okay Street Scene and it's
very important do you think there is
harm to the conservation area this is
really important in the balance
foreign
to the heritage of the area
I think I think that was quite clear
when the representations we've seen I
think that's what councilman this is
getting at it's out of keeping with the
air in it and it's it's I'm in the
conservation how how in the building
Conservation Area consolver development
particularly that care home on on that
website to uh earlier I think that's
reasonable okay sorry that's fine yes is
that okay sorry yeah I didn't know
exactly I don't wish to push the point
but if if we are refusing on on
something like scale of us and when you
have a Heritage asset you have to be
outside and clear whether you think
there is harm to that Heritage asset or
not and if you think there is then
that's fine but we need to know that
sorry thank you thank you
thank you councilman councilor talking
do you want to add anything to that
thank you uh no I don't want to add
anything I think uh the um harms of the
street scene and the damage to the
conservation area is where I would
second uh The Proposal
okay I'm grateful councilor so I think
we've got a reason
um for refusal and we'll vote on the
motion to refuse first which has been uh
moved on seconded so this is the motion
to refuse funding permission uh against
the officer recommendation so all those
members in favor of refusal please
foreign
against refusal please
yeah okay thank you and then we do need
to vote on the motion to uh Grant
permission as per the recommendation so
all those in favor of the granting
please if you could indicate
okay and all those against Grant if you
could indicate please
yeah okay so that motion is carried and
uh planning permission is is uh granted
subject so the church
Comfort break before we move on yeah
okay what else what I'm going to suggest
is um it's coming up to eight o'clock
um so I'm going to suggest we we perhaps
take a five minute Comfort break stretch
our legs and then hopefully we'll move
on uh more quickly on the other items
thank you
wow
snake
back here back at five to eight please
okay thank you counselors we'll we'll
restart we've got other items to get
through on agenda so we'll turn next to
our um application
106.156 which is the land of Trafford
Park Road on page one of your bundle and
we'll have an introduction from Ms Coley
thank you thank you chairman this full
planning application seeks planning
permission for the creation of a waste
handling facility on a cleared
Brownfield site within the industrial
area of traffic Park
the applicant has detailed that the site
would be operated by a private company
and would not be open to the general
public it would predominantly operate as
a commercial and Industrial Waste
Transfer Station with treatment
primarily for the receipt of inert and
Municipal trade waste from the operators
in-house waste collection services to
local businesses and commerce relevant
core strategy and greater management
joint waste development plan policy
identifies the traffic Park area as
suitable for this type of use the
principle of the proposed development is
therefore considered acceptable
the applicant has already obtained an
environmental permit from the
environment agency for the proposed
operations of the waste Transfer Station
22 letters of objection have been
received from residents or businesses
within Trafford of which three are from
businesses within Trafford Park a large
number of the representations received
raised concerns about the impact of The
Proposal on a neighboring Cafe which is
opened opposite the site under permitted
development rights the primary function
of traffic Park is to provide employment
uses largely relating to Industrial
storage and distribution offices and
Waste Management Services it is
protected for these purposes the
presence of this neighboring Cafe and
bar should therefore not unduly restrict
or compromise the uses permitted on the
application site the council's
Environmental Protection Service the
local Highway Authority and the greater
management minerals and waste unit have
commented on the application and raised
no objections
the creation of the proposed waste
transfer station on the site of Travel
Park Road within the core industrial
area of traffic Park will contribute to
local and National waste recycling
targets whilst also bringing a vacant
Brownfield site back into active use the
applicant has identified that the
proposal result in the creation of 20
full-time jobs the proposed development
is considered to be acceptable in terms
of design and appearance and is
reflective of the industrial nature of
Trafford park it is also considered that
the improvements to the front boundary
treatment will have a positive impact on
the existing Street Scene the
development would operate strict
turnaround times for any waste which
could give rise to odors to ensure that
there would be a low risk of odor
nuisance it is therefore recommended
that the application is approved subject
to the condition set out in the report
thank you chair
thank you Miss Coley is um Mr Oliver
with us
Mr Oliver thank you for your patience
um while we dealt with the last item
um if you yeah take a seat opposite me
and just press the button to make sure
the the red light comes on yeah that's
great
um so you'll have three minutes to speak
to us Mr Oliver yeah
on behalf of GV and Sixth Street it's
located directly opposite of Rose Way
site on the roundabout uh GB is a third
generation family-run engineering
company operating there since 1986 with
strong links to Chopper park for service
of a power of Machinery to local
businesses six trees is a part of our
company uh gve and was developed over
the last five years and we opened on the
1st of May 2020 six trees is a bar
restaurant a music venue with a 300
square meter deck Terrier at the front
of the building facing directly onto the
roundabout and proposed waste site a
decision to open 60s was in response to
the development of traffic Park the
construction of the new Metrolink and
the closure both the Travel Park Hotel
and The Village Pub I mean there was no
areas for respite and networking among
the Travel Park Community
uh we have since we've opened the doors
or fast become that space for Community
where colleagues can meet for lunch work
in a car relaxing somewhat beautiful
setting and obviously you've had praise
there's a Oasis in the industrial
setting and just what the area needed
throughout the process we've worked
alongside uh traffic Council and
environmental health and the police to
try and deliver some of the core
development goals creating many new jobs
regenerating local amenities and during
the process we've been granted not one
but two premises license on the current
location uh
solidifying the important parts of the
current traffic Park Community my
understanding is that the application
seeks to build a commercial and and
household way site in small amounts
directly in front of and outside our
restaurant dining space I've got some
pictures showing the view from the site
if you're allowed to see them um showing
the close proximity operations will be
daily with a constant flow of trucks
expected to be 50 or more movements a
day my major concern is in regards to
increasing heavy vehicle traffic to the
area particularly outside licensed
premises this has also been flagged as a
concern when speaking to John Lowe from
the Trafford licensing police and the
turning into the
premises off the roundabout is not
acceptable from the roundabout for a
safe right turn it used to be the exit
point for a one-way system from the
original site and we'll leave drivers
the option and approaching from around a
part of a dangerous U-turn or driving
into the park and looking for a space to
turn have your goods vehicles around
by nature of the site is also going to
produce consistent noise nuisance for
daily operations offensive odors and
dust as I know there is
uh things in place to try and stop this
but we we know with the 20 meter
proximity to our front door and with the
effects that we have on warm days with
the wind direction from the biffer site
over a mile away it's going to be
unavoidable
um all these issues we're going to have
a fun profound effect on both our
customers our number of employees having
to deal with this face-to-face on a
daily basis I also have concerns that
six trees was completely left out of the
initial planning application even though
we were operating at the time of the
site inspection the closed Village or
the Village area and the traffic so
which is closed was mentioned and I'm
sure we were not because the development
was very aware that it's going to have a
direct effect on our business due to its
proximity
[Music]
um
my stance would be to request the
application be rejected on these grounds
as it will have a negative impact not
only on our live Hood but the wider
traffic Copart Community
um I think granting it would certainly
be a major and long-lasting effect to
the viability of the business we've
spent years building thank you okay
thank you thank you so much
um we're not allowed to look at items
that you've brought with you I'm afraid
so um but I know that counselors will
will often have visited the site and
seen a site in situ so yeah apologies we
can't we can't look at documents on on
the day
um we have a speaker in favor Mr Benson
so if you'd like to come and take a seat
please Mr Benson
um you'll also have three minutes to
speak to us so we'll start the clock
once you start speaking thank you
good evening everyone thank you for your
time tonight my name is Thomas Benson
and I'm the agent acting on behalf of
Lancashire and Cumbria demolition I
would wish to summarize the key issues
and underline how the site may be
effectively integrated with the
surrounding area under how environmental
matters will be controlled
Versailles already benefits from an
environmental permit which has been
issued by the environment agency
following a lengthy process of review by
the regulator
details of a relevant permitting
document such as the Environmental
Management System have been provided to
travel to council
follow me with submission of numerous
environmental assessments and statements
as part of the application process
Target Council have confirmed that the
relevant consultations and Specialists
are satisfied about the proposed
development will not result in unwanted
noise dot or odor emissions due to the
relevant controls and mitigation to be
put in place
a list of waste types has been provided
to traffic Council which confirms a vast
majority of incoming wastes will
comprise in a construction and
demolition wastes rather than Municipal
black bag wastes no hazardous wastes to
be accepted at the site
short turnaround times and limited
quantities of on-site waste will also
control the risk of odor for many
residual mini Municipal of wastes this
is limited to 72 hours from receipts of
the waste prior to it leaving the site
which will limit any impacts
the proposed development lies within a
very busy area with a long industrial
Heritage considering the scale of the
proposal so these will not be out of
character with the surrounding area
indeed there are numerous waste related
sites within Trafford Park including
biffer at Trafford Wharf Road and Veolia
located off Nash Road to the West
it should also be noted but the
proposals Accord with national and local
planning policies as demonstrated within
the planning statement and the committee
report
the site is also allocated for Waste
Management within the waste plan
with respect to the previous speaker I
do understand the concerns however it
has been demonstrated that proposals of
a negligible impact as stated previously
the bar is an ancillary used for wider
industrial State and should not
Prejudice employment creation within the
core of industrial area
thank you for your time
thank you very much Mr Benson for
speaking to us uh I'll look for members
now who would like to start the debate
on this item before I maybe come to the
first member um Miss hendren I want uh I
wonder if
um Mr Oliver mentioned the access to the
site and concerns about it being very
close to the roundabout and uh I wonder
if you could
give us any advice on uh to the extent
to which that was assessed as part of
this application thank you yes
um there is an existing neighboring
business which is an hgv
um sales business
and sight lines visibility splays and
vehicle tracking were also provided
um and it demonstrated that hgvs can
turn in and out of there and the
um Collision history for the site
doesn't highlight a road safety concern
either existing or emerging for that
particular location and certainly
nothing that would be associated with
that particular access
thank you very much that is very helpful
any members looking to start their bait
counselor Welton
thank you chair um yeah I can very much
understand the concerns of six trees um
kitchen bar um when you've developed a
business like this and with some outdoor
seating space particularly and
somebody's going to be proposing a waste
site just across the road I can
understand why that would be you know
very concerning and
um
and we have a you know I we have a waste
site in alteringham for example there's
a of a similar nature and we we do have
problems
um with that site it's very located very
close to some you know some residential
areas and and I'm familiar with the
problems that can can come from from
these um these sites having said that I
don't see I mean I think the the report
sets out quite clearly that there aren't
any
planning issues
um that you know that you could you can
look at is it the pollution that is
potentially problematic but we don't it
doesn't give us a planning reason to
um to turn this down and and any issues
with the site are really the the
um the uh for the environment agency
um to deal with as we do in altering
with with the site we frequently have to
you know we've unfortunately we've had
frequently had to to get the environment
agency to
um to get the the site to uh to be run
properly hopefully that wouldn't be the
case in this site because it's it will
be run properly from the start and
follow all it's all the procedures and
and things like that
um but that is their responsibility I
don't see that that there's any planning
reasons to turn this down and I remember
would be happy to um to propose that we
accept this
as the recommendation to approve thank
you thank you cancer Welton um cancer
akinola
uh I just wanted to ask a quick question
was there any assessment regarding noise
because I couldn't see anything in the
report other than ITV bringing it up as
an issue uh I believe so
um Council just bear with me
there was yes uh the applicant submitted
a noise assessment with the application
then
um
if if you look at the comments of our
environmental which is environmental
projection but it is obviously meant to
say Environmental Protection nuisance uh
they had no objections
um and they accept the position that the
control of these impacts will fall to
the environment agency through their
permit conditions which should not
um duplicate planning um be duplicated
by planning conditions in this instance
questions
okay so I can always did you want to
comment as well or just the question for
a moment
it well it is a trading estate isn't it
it's really difficult and um although I
do have sympathy for um particularly for
the cafe and uh other businesses that
are there it is a trading industrial
estate that's what it was set up for
thank you counselor Winston
uh thank you chair I'm gonna back out
what uh Council racket illness I'd have
great sympathy for
um for Mr Oliver I do but it's an
interesting State it's been a nurse
because it's been there 100 years
um the site itself was previously used
as a as an industrial site there's
there's a license already been issued by
the environment agency my one concern
was when I went to visit the site was as
was raised in the um what Mr Oliver said
about the way hdb isn't getting to the
site but that's been unpronounced by the
highways team over here so I'm afraid
I'll be voting in in favor of this
thank you councilman's down the
councilor Freeman
um following on from councilor wetton
who's proposed that the uh sorry
well okay Mike it's easy to following on
I will second the uh the proposal that
we accept uh an officer recommendation
okay thank you Council Freeman any other
members looking to speak councilor
Proctor I just want to move to vote
please
okay I'll just check any other members
wanting to speak take a different View
now okay
well it has been uh a movement seconded
that we but we Grant permission in
accordance with the officer
recommendation
um so we'll vote on that now so
um all those uh in favor of granting
Planet permission please
[Music]
that is uh unanimous okay thank you
everybody so that application is is
granted
and thank you to uh Mr Oliver Mr Benson
for coming to speak to us we'll move on
to the next application uh 108 723 which
is 16 burlesque Drive in sale starts on
page 111 of your um your bundle there's
no speakers uh for or against this item
and we will have an introduction uh from
Miss Coley thank you
thank you chairman this application
relates to a two-story semi-detached
property located on bonus drive and sale
planning permission is sought for the
erection of a single story side and rear
extension the application has been
reported to committee because the
applicant is a member of Staff in the
place directorate no representations
have been received
it is considered that proposed extension
is acceptable in terms of design and
visual immunity and would not have an
unacceptable impact on the residential
immunity of neighboring dwellings as
such it is considered that the proposed
development would be in accordance with
policy L7 of the core strategy and
guidance to the mppf and the application
is therefore recommended for approval
subject to conditions thank you thank
you Miss curly any members looking to
speak on this item councilor Freeman yes
um just to move it to a vote
and and I propose that we accept the
officer recommendation
thank you Council premium councilor
brunting you're seconding that
yes sir
yes another item of agreement between
councilor Freeman and councilor bunting
so uh
I do agree I think I think the report is
um comprehensive and I can't see any
issue with any of the members looking to
speak on this item no okay it has been
moving and seconded that we that we
Grant permission us for the
recommendation so all those in favor of
granting if you could indicate please
thank you very much so that is uh
unanimous as well so that application is
granted thank you
so we'll move on now to item uh number
seven which is the article 18
consultation from Cheshire East Council
um relating to the proposed Motorway
service area and we will start with an
introduction from uh Mr Pearson thank
you thank you chairman as you say it's a
consultation from Cheshire East under
the Town and Country Planning
Development management procedure order
in relation to a planning application
that they've received for their action
of the motorway service area
the sites located entirely within the
administrative area of Cheshire East
um an adjacent to the m56 motorway
between Junctions seven and eight
the site and its surroundings are within
the green belt
the proposed development comprises an
amenity building with Farm shop and
kitchen a 100 bedroom hotel a fuel Barn
Filling Station 655 car parking spaces
58 hgv spaces plus spaces for coaches
and Caravans motorhomes cycles and
motorcycle parking and other Associated
works all existing buildings on the site
are to be demolished with the exception
of the existing Farmhouse which will be
retained for for operational purposes
for the for the motorway service area
the proposals inappropriate development
in a in the green belt should only be
approved if very special circumstances
exist which outweigh the potential harms
of the green belt by reason of
inappropriateness and any other harm
resulting from The Proposal
in support of the application the
applicant considers the proposal would
result in relatively limited harm to
openness and that very special
circumstances exist in that there's a
need for a Motorway service area in this
location having guard to Department of
Transport guidance on the distance
between roadside facilities
whether or not this need amounts to very
special circumstances that clearly
outweigh the harms of the green belt
is a matter for Cheshire East Council
given that the application site is lies
entirely within their administrative
area
the proposed development includes Town
Center uses retail Leisure and hotel and
as such must be subject to sequential
tests and impact tests
it's considered that the applicant has
satisfied both the sequential test and
the impact assessment as required by
national policy and has demonstrated
that the proposals would not have a
significance adverse impact on the
vitality and viability of alteringham
and other centers in Trafford
it's considered that the proposals would
result in harm to the landscape and
Heritage assets specifically Watch Hill
scheduled ancient Monument however this
could be at this harm could be
adequately mitigated by additional tree
planting on the Northern side of the
application site and so our recommended
recommendation includes the inclusion
condition uh to that effect
the additional information report
includes comments from councilor Jerome
regarding the potential impact on
alteringham Hale and Bowden and an
amendment to the recommendation
recommended condition relating to the
retail floor space to cap the amount of
retail and Leisure for space and to
limit the amount of comparison goods for
space thank you chairman
thank you Mr Pearson um no speakers on
this item so any members looking to
speak councilor chalkin
[Music]
um I apologies to members in advance but
I do actually object to this
um and I'm a bit
um I mean this is way out of my
knowledge area and and so I'm looking
for guidance on this but
I take issue with the idea that there
aren't enough service stations for
starters there's Lin Lim not that far
down the road there's the airport city
the next Junction up so I take issue
that that's going to be special
circumstances my biggest problem aside
from the damage to the
um Greenbelt which I know can be
mitigated and I do know who the
applicant is as I'm sure most of us do
and I know that they have a chart record
of of of developing nice service
stations so you know I'm sure they'll do
a good job there but my biggest problem
is the traffic on the M60 m56 and the
a556
um
and again this is probably Strays way
out of our bounds of our remit but um
that's Motorway leading up to vote
injunction is currently
um being upgraded to a Smart Motorway
Network to deal with traffic it is going
to be
um it isn't going to work because the
problem there is hgvs
um going up a hill which slows
everything down and causes a massive
backlash down to the uh to the airport
um that's adding this to that is that a
wise decision is that something we
should be considering um because that
then has knock-on effects everywhere
else in the surrounding area my other
problem and okay this is a short-term
problem is that
hs2 is coming
um Junction whatever it is at the
airport I can never remember the number
that's going to disappear for probably
six or seven years you know that's well
this gets reject the traffic is going to
then be diverted down here
um down the ffo6 and that that building
Junction so you know
I don't again this is a more voicing my
concerns here and I don't really know
where Trafford sits in its ability to
raise any of those but I think it's
worth talking about
awesome
fantastic thank you Council talking for
raising those matters um
came so well to not come to you thank
you thank you chair
um yeah I can't support this
recommendation I mean I know I
understand what it says about the final
decision being a matter for Cheshire
East but uh
I I have written that I feel it's a
cop-out maybe a week is a better a
better word to use not to give A View
From trafford's perspective I don't see
why we can't say that that you know that
there is that there's no special
circumstance for building an MSA on the
green belt at this you know at this
point why can't we
make that representation and at least
point it out from our point of view I
mean for the motorist it will be nice to
have but it's far from an essential
addition to the facilities available in
the region which are all available
within a short distance for those who
really need them and the you know the
m56 is not a long Motorway it's not the
m6 it's not the M
um the M5 you know with people traveling
hundreds of miles on it it's a it's a
Motorway you join for a bit and even if
you drive it on the whole whole of it
it's you know it's only an hour it's
only an hour long
um
uh you know what this what it will be is
the opportunity to place a huge out of
town Farm shop with free parking close
to a major wealthy population Center and
for me it's a license to print money
it'll be a major generator of additional
cartoon Journeys in our Borough and
we'll directly compete with many of our
local retailers whether it's the
marketing altering them shops like
booths and hail barns or rural
businesses like the little Heath Farm
shop in Dunham Massey
and I fully agree with the objections
submitted by the boat and conservation
society that Westmoreland cannot be
treated as a regular MSA given its
enhanced retail offer and that its
retail response is floor and that it
um westmoreland's own retail response is
flawed given that it fails to compare
like with like
um the project does come with welcome
green trimmings okay and it will
generate some jobs though others may be
lost elsewhere however this will not
compensate for the loss of green belt to
consumerism and the impact that it will
have on our worsening climate and bio
biodiversity emergencies if I was on the
planning committee at Cheshire East I
would hope I would stand up for the
green belt and provide some reasoned
objections for this project and I think
it's a shame to see our Council duck the
opportunity to do the same thank you
okay cancel the welcome so um I'll
perhaps turn to Miss Kelly or Miss
Pearson just for some advice on
what the effect is of
Trafford as an authority object into the
application and it might be on the
ground you've suggested if we were
minded to do that thank you
um
you can overturn the office of
recommendation here you don't have to go
with it you can object if this committee
wants to object then we can object
um we would need to write to to Cheshire
East before their planning committee
which is taking place next week and set
out our objection
um then I have to take a new notice of
this
um
but
but just bear with me the other thing
that we could do if members were so
minded if you do feel very strongly
about it is right to the Secretary of
State uh with something called a request
to intervene whereby
um you say effectively we have a very
strong objection to this therefore if
Cheshire Easter minded to approve it
pleased with the Secretary of State call
it in for their own determination as a
so effectively take that decision out of
cheshire's hands however that would then
lead to something called a call in
inquiry
um and we having raised that objection
would then be expected to go and justify
that objection at that inquiry so that
that so you need to be confident that
you you think we could justify that
objection because dragging something
into a call and inquiry if it's not
justified
um again this is something that could
lead to cost yes so so we need to we
need to be we need to be very sure if if
you want to take that particular request
to intervene
um of course Secretary of State my might
say thanks Trafford we've heard you but
no we're not going to intervene they
they make so we may never get to that
but we have to bear in mind what it
could go to if that's if that's where
members want to take it
um thank you that's very well councilor
Morgan uh thank you chair I've I've only
been to one of the Westmoreland um
service station not went to the Cairns
or Gloucester one but I'm sure others
have gone to the cumbrian
um service station it's great if you're
driving that far north actually we
deliberately would stop at that service
station it's a amazing it's so much
nicer than any other service station I
think I've ever been in
um but the cumbrian one definitely is a
service station it's in the middle of
utter nowhere
um and um sorry any cumbrance but it is
there's not a lot of that
um but it is there is not anything
nearby
I object this being defined as a
Motorway service station it is not there
because it's murder so it's there
because it's they want to put all the
retail outlet they want to build a
retail outlet south of hail south of
Bowden north of nutsford south of
Altrincham near with tons of traffic I
go past this route most days
um going to work
um there is service stations not that
far along it is
even with the m56 roadworks it's tops 10
minutes to the airport
um you can get into altering in 10
minutes from this Junction you can get
to Lim in in 10 minutes I mean get to
the m6 in less a lot less than 10
minutes
um there is no reason for special
circumstances in the Green Mill I know
that isn't actually a determination of
ours
um but I definitely think there is the
damage to the Heritage asset
is unmistakable
um and on the sequential test I do think
this will have an adverse impact on
Ultra it's deliberately designed to
appeal to Residents who live in my ward
and who go to
um to booths to go to hail who go to
alteringham
um I I can't see there's any there is
not any impact and then there's the as
with councilor Walton has already said
in terms of the impacts on traffic this
is going to generate traffic
um on that Junction now whether there is
a is a problem
um Junction as it is it generates
traffic in ultragon which I think all of
us would agree is
um we want to try and reduce
um so I will not be supporting this but
and we need to have a debate about what
we do do but there's no way that I I'm
prepared to accept
um we don't have objections to this
thank you
thank you councilor Morgan uh councilor
akinella I just wanted to ask is um
objections on the on the basis of that
the impact on altering him and other
businesses is that actually something
that would be considered because I
thought that wasn't a planning thing
oh it's it's appropriate to consider the
impact that it might have on the retail
centers
um you know and we've employed our own
uh planning Consultants uh or our
retained retail Consultants to have a
look at these impacts to see what the
the applicant had suggested whether that
that was the case or not
um and there are two tests as a
sequential impact test so you've got to
look to see whether it's a site within a
town center on the edge of a town center
that could accommodate the proposed use
and that's very clearly not the case uh
and then the other is about the impact
on either planned investment or existing
development uh investment or the impact
on the vitality and viability of those
centers so our Consultants have had a
look at the the submission from the
applicants and they've concluded that
there would be a less than one percent
trade diversion from those centers so
and the test that we have to look at is
significant adverse impact on Those
sensors so you know there's no
reasonable way you could say that
um that's a loss of less than one
percent trade from those centers
equated to a significant adverse impact
that's our view on on that point
thank you Mr Pearson
um councilor win Stanley
uh thank you chair
um I think I was instinctively against
this when I when I saw what the
proposals were against it on two grounds
one was about to build in the green belt
and one was the impact on a local Town
Center
um
then when I went and looked at the map
and realized where it was that section
the green belt is basically a very large
traffic island in the middle of
um m56 and e8556
um so the only harm there would be to
the Heritage asset
which is Watch Hill that'll be covered
by the
um by more planting to to mask the site
second objection is to say was the
impact it would have on Ultra human bone
and Newton Highland on the other the
town centers nearby I read the report it
was all written by the people the
applicants and I thought yeah well they
would say that would know it's got not
gonna have any impact if they're going
to say it's going to have an impact and
then I read the report which we had con
we had commissioned from a set of
independent Consultants who also said
minimal impact
um and I don't think that people who are
going to stay in the hotels in the in
that on that site uh will detract from
that business within the local Town
centers and in fact if somebody spent
far too many nights staying in the Days
Inn on uh Warwick Services as you shut
backwards and forwards if you stay in
those hotels because you're traveling
and it's designed for people traveling
up and down the motorway you will end up
generating more business in the local
area there's only so many times you can
walk around the farm shop
so I actually think that this will be
okay and I'm happy with the officer
recommendation to to raise no objection
thank you chair
thank you thank you Cam so much Stanley
um councilor bunting
yes thank you chairman I'm gonna agree
with my colleagues out on the other side
over there who argue there is a
substantial ground for an objection and
it's clear in my view that there are no
special
tribe quite frankly
um the argument that there are no other
service stations here is this has been
pointed out it is not the case it's
clearly a a basically a good excuse to
create a retail outlet in the green belt
to the south of relatively Pros well to
to both in both South and in other
directions for relatively prosperous
areas they're going to drive out
specifically to go and get to use the
farm shops and all that kind of thing on
on this site it's uh you know hopefully
um my our colleagues in
Cheshire East will see straight through
this and come to pretty much the same
conclusion although we'll have to wait
and find out I suppose whilst I would be
quite happy to uh support the you know
an objection to to the to the council
itself I think maybe going to the
secretary of state is taking this a bit
too far
um I'm I'm sure that if we were dealing
with a site in Trafford and other
councils were pitching in we'd be saying
what on Earth they've got to do with you
matey you know we'll make our own
decisions on this one thanks very much
so writing to them and raising our
objections although those objections May
well be in their minds already so it may
may be relatively pointless in many ways
yeah they're either going to agree with
us and and would have refused it on
those grounds anyway or they're going to
disagree with us and disregard the
objection uh I suppose on on a point of
principle I think it would be a
reasonable thing to object on the ground
so there are no special circumstances on
the ground so it will have an impact
upon uh upon the Heritage I said okay
that can be mitigated by additional
planting but not removed entirely it is
going to generate additional traffic as
it draws people to it who are going to
go specifically to this uh to this
location views of that retail uh use and
it is going to have at least a marginal
impact on uh on other term centers so I
think there is a reason to write to to
Cheshire Eastern object uh although I
would not support uh the uh Secretary of
State you know because the
psychologistics I think that's a
successive given circumstances thank you
chairman okay thank you Council Bunton
councilor Freeman
thanks a few years ago in 2016 this
committee approved an application from
Euro garages to build a drive-through
coffee shop in my ward off the M60
and it was done on the chairs custom
vote
depart despite the fact we came with all
the information and the biggest fear
then were the two office blocks in that
of complex were empty but they were
going to create a service station just
off the M60 in Salem OR Ward
unhappy with this report as it is this
is Cheshire East it's not Trafford and
and I'm sorry you know uh it's like I'm
listening to a lot it's not like not in
my backyard here listening to what I've
heard around this table
um it's their land it's their
application it's there for them to
consider and I've read this report like
councilwin Stanley has and I'm happy
with the content of it I'm happy with
the with the recommendation that's made
thank you very much okay thank you
councilor Freeman
um so
councilor bunting uh was of the I think
pretty clear view that we we didn't ask
the Secretary of State to intervene and
call it in so I'd be interested in
hearing if any member thinks we should
do that or whether we're just talking
about should we object or or not object
okay with that I'll come back to Canada
Welton
thank you uh I just answered uh
councilor Freeman's point is that
actually our um Bowden Altrincham are
the closest urban centers to this and
therefore we have a direct we have a we
have a direct responsibility you know to
see that this you know there's something
when something is proposed like this on
our doorstep it's not not in my backyard
it's literally in our backyard you know
and it's going to have a big impact on
our area and I'm sorry if we you know if
we respond when that happens but we're
going to do that
um I will would support it going you
know
um a request to intervene I think there
is a danger that this for some for for
um you know I'm not a cheshirees
counselor but it may be because this is
where it is it is much more of uh an
issue for us than Perhaps it is for them
because this is not affecting their
major Urban population areas whereas it
is affecting our major you know some of
our major Urban population areas I can
see that it might be quite easy for them
to pass it thinking okay you know it's
not not a major issue for us it's a
major major issue for them it is a major
issue for us I think and I think it
would be good to have the backup of uh
of the requests to you know to intervene
so therefore if they do pass it then we
have the opportunity to State our case
and say that it is inappropriate
development on you know on the
um on the edge of our Borough it's a
inappropriate use of the green belt or
the terminology escapes me right now so
I would propose that we do um
we do request to intervene if not then
if I don't get a second then I'm also
happy to um to Second the proposal to um
to at least object thank you very much
okay thank you Council Welton um
I'll just come to miss Kohler just just
to advise on the uh the mechanics around
intervention and who might intervened
thank you
um anybody can put in a request to
intervene so if the committee didn't
move the request of intervene if you
felt very strongly about it counselor
you could do that as an individual or
with the other altering objectors and uh
if the if it was called in you could
then appear as something that's known as
a rule six party at the inquiry albeit
you would probably need some legal
advice we would need you would need
leave advice but that but you wouldn't
be appearing you you you'd be appearing
as counselor Wilton but not as on behalf
of Trafford as local planning Authority
representing your residence
so but you obviously don't need to do so
decide that now but but and that will be
open to any any one of you to support
councilor Welton or or not again as a
ward council
okay I'll leave you with that thought
cancer Welton
councilor Proctor
very proud West cumbrian
[Music]
tea Bay is my favorite
absolute favorite service station
but we don't need it on the m56 it
doesn't make sense
it's a short little Motorway
if it was built I'd have to
probably chain my family into the house
to stop them going
because they're and I hate to say this
as a vegan they're black pudding pork
pies I think my husband would probably
crawl over hot coals to get one and eat
it
foreign
but this it's not necessary and I'd
object to it on Heritage grounds I'd
object to it on it is green belts
I'd objective on it we don't need it and
I'm tempted actually to um support my
colleague as an individual
because I think that way Trafford
wouldn't be at any risk you I probably
need advice on that from and Rebecca the
council itself would it's extremely uh
rare that a raw sex party would have any
awards or costs against them as long as
they were reasonable and representing
the community
you're on
I'm looking forward to the process about
cancer the Proctor of uh you defending
the green belt or else your husband
tries to barge pass you to get those
um
um uh yeah I I would um
sorry counselor bunting you you well
cancel Hassan you wanted to come in I I
think just at this point I would uh I
would be of the strong view that we do
not recommend at the counseling today
um because of the risk as the costs
because of the reasons people of Artic
you know articulated I'm and I'm not
sure the grounds for us to object to
this so that's strong and uh so I
wouldn't feel comfortable
um subjecting to council to that risk of
of costs
um so I certainly would want to relate
that option but I know councilor Welton
you were you were thinking about that
but I'll come to
um councilor Hassan now thank you
I don't think we I mean I'm disagree
with my friend uh and uh this can I ask
the question could officers what what
kind of uh uh shopping centers are there
what they are going to build there in in
sorry
it is a farm shop it's a farm shop
cheeses they'll be
um Meats they'll be and then and then
you've got a cafe area but then you've
got the store that does the sausage
rolls are great actually
this is
and all sorts and and then there'll be
an area
so this is going to affect the
alternative Town Center so I disagree
with my friend uh this app m56 it is not
all about m56 my friend because it if
that Junction connects to M6 the people
traveling from M6 all the way from cells
it connects to towards to birkenhead all
the way down to Chester and of course
it's connected to M60 as well so it is
it is the point where the Travelers are
coming to stay and have a cup of tea and
a shop and go they are not coming for
shopping center my friend and and it I'm
totally agreed with my colleague Mike
Freeman so it is a it is dairy she's not
nothing to do with us it is it is not
going to affect our business at all I
mean nobody is going from Stratford or
ordering for shopping to that
no I mean don't make sense and things
people are traveling so then I I mean I
think I I
I don't I think it is for The Travelers
and it is connecting from all the way
down to Chester's to Manchester and all
Scotland as well MC is coming from south
all the way around towards Jesters it is
connecting it is it is uh it is a hub
for the people to stay calm relax cup of
tea and go so it is not a shopping
center my friend green belt green so if
it is a green belt it is nothing to do
with Trafford then
corporations in agreed okay I've got uh
councilor bunting councilor minis
um and then I think we need to try and
move to some votes on this and decide
what we're going to do in terms of um uh
of objecting on our intervening uh
Council bunting yes thank you I wish you
hadn't mentioned those parts making it
very difficult to do the right thing
uh yeah and on those grounds if it was
good you say I could see people going
there to cook you know stock up you know
go and buy buy some nice uh nice
commentables like uh so I could see
people you know sort of traveling if it
in in that way but in terms of two
points onto me in terms of risk to the
council if we're simply objecting
writing a letter to the support and
objection that's some that's not us
making a decision that's not as
intervening directly in the process
there was no real risk to the Council on
that basis all that's doing is possibly
providing a little bit of ammunition to
a uh Cheshire East counselor who wishes
to sort of objects we can say well he's
at least got a backing of the of another
Authority that is going to be directly
impacted upon it right so so that is the
only thing that you'd really do as a
result of this and just the other point
in terms of the charge of nimbyism I
wanted to point out that the site of the
Council of Friedman mentioned is far
closer to my ward than this site is I
voted in favor of the other side and I'm
going against this one so this has got
nothing with Nimbus and this is nowhere
near
so the idea that I'm doing this is sort
of my backyard issue is nowhere near my
backyard
um the other site that Council fever
mentioned was far far closer to my War
than would have had more of an impact on
my War than this site will so I I don't
agree with that point though but I'm
certainly saying if we simply writer if
we somebody raise out an objection but
leave it in the hands of Cheshire East I
can see no risk to this Council on on
background and that's where I propose
that we we do raise an objection to
Cheshire East and let them make the
decision this is their Turf not ours
thank you chairman okay thank you can
respond to cancel a minute
I'm more than happy to second that and
the thing is it's
I mean I I love TV services I absolutely
love it
um and uh for councilman Hassan it's
amazing you go there you'll understand
right but what I'd rather see it replace
is that welcome break at Keel that's
what I'd rather see it replace rather
than go here so um and the thing is
people will it's amazing people will go
there instead of our places
um and it those businesses will suffer
so I know you're thinking oh it's a
service station it's just a little shop
no go to eBay you'll understand if
you've been to TB you'll get it right
it's got lovely chocolates it's got Gins
it's got everything it's got everything
in there right honestly people will then
go there instead of where we want them
to go so um it's the green belt it's not
a special circumstances
um it's not
as naturally on the m6 like you know
um
it I think yes we go we go with an
objection and that way we don't shaft
Trafford Council but
um it may prompt something further
further east I think is the right way
I'm not comfortable with saying it's
okay even though I do love TB services
thank you for that uh disclosure cancel
the minute um
I I also like TB and
I've also been to I've also been to
Gloucester
um
and uh
I mean yeah I mean actually Gloucester
is a is a is a better design actually
because it's got a grass roof I think
hasn't it and it is quite sort of
concealed
um wasn't that Keen on the design of
this one
[Laughter]
take some time to uh do all that
catering I think um okay so uh it has
been moved and seconded that we that we
do object uh councilor Freeman I think
you were happy not to not to object uh
and a an encounter the Winston you were
happy to do that sorry cancel the world
appreciate it just to come in briefly um
I uh I'm with the councils who've spoken
against this because of the effects it
it'll have an ALT yeah I can see that
but the evidence from the reports as
councilor when Stanley said it doesn't
stack up and when this objection goes
through to Cheshire East they will turn
around and say well hang on a minute
it's only going one percent effect on
ulti you know so how do we argue how do
you argue that I know people are sincere
but but I can't see how we can we can
get around those those facts and I think
it's been independently assessed as well
a one percent in alticum wouldn't be
significant enough for an objection so I
think we've got to support it uh chair
or rather not not object in in the way
has been described
yeah thank you Council Wall Street I
hear your concern I think if we so it
has been moving a second don't we
objects I do think we need to be clear
what what our reasons for objection will
be and I'm not I'm not convinced about
the um attempts and to use as for the
reasons you've said um councilor Wilson
did you want to speak again uh yes I
mean I think if you read the Bowdoin
conservation Society
um uh objection or um or comment at
least they you know I didn't got the
right yes from building conservation
Society uh
uh you know they're pointing out some
flaws in you know in in the way that
this has been you know this has been
weighed up you know they're basically
they're saying this is a regular
Motorway service station and you know
and and they're looking at the impact
that that would have on on the local
area but this is not I think we know and
we've this meeting is made you know if
anything's become clear these are not
regular Motorway service stations they
need to be tested on a different level
and I don't feel like that that has you
know that that has happened yet and I
think you know I I think we can say that
we believe that that you know in our
experience and we have a wide experience
of using these services and you know and
the reasons why people go to them that
it will become a destination you know
not just for people who are passing
through in their cars but also for local
people as well and it will you know and
that will you know certainly has the
potential to thank you very much uh I'm
sorry
um will damage on Our Town centers but
the major point you know the major point
is that this is Greenbelt Land Greenbelt
Land it needs special circumstances
for you know to to justify building on
it this is not a special circumstance
you know this is emotion you know this
is a Motorway service station that's not
really needed in the area I mean if you
need petrol there's literally a petrol
station you know within a few hundred
meters just up the uh you know there are
up the a56 you know so
but you want to get it together exactly
you know so so we're awesome so we're
asking ourselves why you know why you
know you know pies are not special
circumstances for very on the green belt
and at the very least we need to say
that to Cheshire East I mean goodness
for me I think we're letting our
residents down if we don't say that
goodness okay
um
okay uh the the passions are running
high on this item I know but uh we are
still we are still live streaming
um I appreciate it's not our decision
but I I do think we do need to
articulate some decent ground subject uh
I'm probably with you councilor Wilson
that I think the
um the green belt and no very special
circumstances is a better reason to
object than the term Center impact
um so it has been moving seconded that
we object and also that we that we don't
object uh cancer Welton you were minded
to move that the council intervene I
don't know if you are still persisting
enough
okay
okay yeah seconding the council
intervene that's
okay
well that's up to you you can start that
out after the meeting but
okay so it hasn't been hasn't been
seconded that the council intervene so
that's not an option
um are a reason for objecting is the uh
the development on Greenbelt and we
don't think there are very special
circumstances that will be why we object
cancer bunting do you want to add
anything to that also chairman
is is that objection because you don't
believe there will be a need for the
facility yes yes yeah that's fine okay
yeah there are there are no specials or
other services in the area that people
can use
plus I also feel that although there is
mitigation with exhibitional planting to
the North in terms Heritage asset I'm
not entirely convinced of that
mitigation that mitigation will be
absolute so there will be an impact you
can argue as to how much it's reduced by
the additional parking but I don't
believe you can wipe it out altogether
so it's still going to be an impact
which I think is unwarranted on that on
that Heritage on that so on those uh on
those that's in a second now except that
there will be a minimal impact upon
the other set of the other centers in
terms of trade being drawn away but I'm
not and that might be as a footnote but
it's certainly not the main reason to
say I would put yeah the fact there are
no special circumstances and the impact
and the impact on Heritage as the second
one with possibly a small or by the way
there is a small impact on Town Center
on the other on trades as well that's
fine because the green belt test is
Green Belt harm and any other harm so
the Heritage so you would need to
outweigh the any Heritage arm as well in
very special circumstances
just reminded me about the um the
highways points because uh again
I just I'm thinking if I said uh can we
weigh in on the impact to the local Road
Network or or not
maybe the way to do it is to say object
on Greenbelt openness visual impact
inappropriate development no very
special circumstances Heritage charm
because all of those are identified and
raise concern about impact on Town
centers and impact on road Network so
it's not not as strong
I'm not a concern as well okay so all
right yeah we've got our we've got our
suggested reasons to object and express
concern so we'll vote on the uh on the
motion that we do object for those
reasons first so all those in favor of
objecting please will you indicating
there
okay and all those against objecting if
you indicate no
okay
and
[Laughter]
into that okay okay
well
okay so that motion is carried um so we
uh we will recommend that we object to
the application for the reasons that um
Miss Coley set out so that is the end of
that item
um moving on now to the next item which
is the Civic quarter area action plan
um and I'll uh turn to miss Coley to
give us an introduction to this item
thank you
the Civic quarter error action plan has
been in progress since 2019 at the Civic
quarter which forms part of Old Trafford
contains a number of important Civic and
sporting assets keyword Redevelopment
opportunity sites has good public
transport links it has been recognized
as having the potential for significant
transformational change this could
support wider growth and investment
across Northern Trafford the area action
plan provides a statutory policy
framework in order that this changes
delivered appropriately and managed
effectively contained within 11 key
policies the plan supports a provision
of up to 4 000 new homes and 50 000
square meters of new commercial floor
space it is focused on achieving high
quality design securing significant new
public realm encouraging sustainable
patterns of movement and providing model
living conditions whilst protecting the
amenities of existing residents the plan
also contains an Innovative Equalization
strategy to ensure that essential
infrastructure is provided alongside new
development 25 affordable housing is
also sought
the AAP has been prepared in accordance
with the necessary regulations it has
been subject to three rounds of public
consultation and a week of public
hearing sessions
an independent inspector appointed to
examine the plan has concluded that
planning sound subject to the
incorporation of agreed main
modifications at meetings next week the
executive will be asked to approve the
final content of the plan in accordance
with the conclusions of the inspector
and then full Council will be asked to
adopt it subject to no legal challenge
the AAP will then form part of the
statutory development plan it will be
the starting point for planning
application decision taking in this in
the Civic quarter thank you thank you
Miss curly um this report report is
promoting so I don't think we need to
take any vote on it but um uh so that
the approval will go to executive and
then full Council in the next couple of
weeks but I don't know if any members
want to speak on this item before we
move on
I'm just um
we need a plan going forward for the
Civic courts and it's quite detailed um
are there opportunities to go against
the plan
things come to committee and you know
members are uh you know
feel very strongly about issues and and
disagree with others
be interested what scope there is to go
against uh what what's what's in the
actual fine detail not not the report
tonight but but the finer detail that's
been provided previously
so it's an industry basis for decision
making so decisions should be made in
accordance with it if you've just
adopted it then you shouldn't
immediately try and go against it
because that would you know what what's
the point but there will always be cases
where there are material considerations
which may outweigh the plan and you
might and you may find those those come
up if you need to think very carefully
about those because you don't want to to
undermine it that's the policies there's
guidance at the effectively at the back
of the plan in terms of design and
neighborhoods and and other things which
is guidance as opposed to policy and
that that is
um intended to be more flexible and
doesn't form the heart of the policies
in the plan but but effectively
um describes a way of
implementing the plan which may or may
not be the way that that happens
just thinking there's a scope for the
discussion debate within within
committee and applications come to us in
the Civic War oh of course yeah
thank you Council Wallace yeah it's a
good question
um so I know members have the
opportunity to speak on this at Council
uh councilor Morgan you wanted to speak
uh thank you chair really really quick
um one of my first ever meetings with
you Miss Kelly was after I just got
elected in 2019 was on this report
um so um it's um nearly four years later
um I just kind of like first like to say
I know huge huge amount of work has gone
into it and over four years um and
anyone who's tried to read
the volumes of of of uh PDFs on the on
the council website it's a huge huge
piece of work and I have to be honest I
I think it's a really positive
development actually in terms of
I imagine when we all talk to our
residents one of the things and you know
there's a debate about beauty and all of
these the the these issues but actually
this is kind of what planning really
should be about it allows you to plan an
area rather than just planning building
by building by building
um and I think I I Others May disagree
but I think this is the sort of thing
which actually will give residents what
they want to have in an area um so I
think it's really positive development
and just thank all the officers for the
huge amount of years of work
are doing um yeah I think it's really
positive development
um you know I'd really like to commend
the planning team on the work they've
put into it you have several rounds of
consultation several drafts
um it's reassuring in a way that the
inspector did make some modifications I
think that probably gives us more
Assurance on the on the legal soundness
and unlikely to be challenged and yeah
it allows us to plan in a much more
strategic way for that for that area and
we've had a lot of applications in the
area already where it's been in the
background and we've said well the area
action plan was in place we could have
more control over the height of
buildings and that sort of thing so um I
think it's a really positive development
for the for the Civic quarter and I'm
yeah really looking forward to seeing
how it how it takes shape over the
coming years cancel the proctor
thank you chat I've got a question I'm
looking at issue two item number 60
gotta take my glasses off now
um about requirements in relation to the
accessible and adaptable home standards
so
how will how will this fit in with the
development plan that we're working in
that we're working on where we are
looking to have
um lifetime homes as a standard for all
homes
just how does it fit
it effectively uh paves the way for that
one as well so this what the um
what the Civic quarter action plan
requires is that all homes every single
one of them are built to m42 standards
which I know
um Council property you're very keen on
as are lots of other members of of this
committee so so it does that and we were
really pleased that the inspector
um has supported that modification and
and thought it was the right thing to do
um as well as as well as being necessary
so
um the local plan will will follow
however
it's likely that before the local
planners adopted we have two things we
have PFE places for everyone which also
has the same requirement for all
dwellings to be built to m42 and also
the building regulations for m42 are
likely to become mandatory in a couple
of years so actually
by the time you get to the local plan
you might not actually need it so don't
worry if it comes out over there that'll
be because you've got to do it for
another reason and if we got Civic
quarter reports we probably wouldn't put
a condition on at that point because it
would be mandatory anyway
that is fantastic thank you thank you
Miss curly yeah really really welcome
information I think um okay another
members I can speak so I think I think
we're happy to note that report and it
will go forward to uh executive
um and then cancel for a decision uh
item nine is no urgent business to
consider I don't think so uh with that I
will close the meeting thank you thank
you everyone